when you see a young actor who's not
focused how do you bring them into the
present the only thing I can do is give
them information and say listen I'm not
in any way trying to stop you from
dreaming but it's a lot of dreamers I
hear only not many make it not many
really reach their dreams in order to do
that you have to be focused with a plan
and even if this plan doesn't work you
have to you can don't ever give up when
you give you know I say
you know whatever you empower the stroke
and create or destroy you you know it's
like if you it's if you're not
responsible your own life and you are
not moving ahead and you're not doing
this and you're succumbing to all of the
resistances that come along with maybe
trying to achieve anything great you are
that resistance so it's a big giant so
what he's got a toe bite it they want
you to think he's invincible that's his
job because he's big yeah okay
you you stick a pin in a giant toe it's
only a pin just stick it in there you
know and then you have to calculate
which way it's gonna fall because you
want to go that way
you